(audience cheering)
- Good evening.
Good evening, good evening.
Oh, Angela. (clicks tongue)
Tonight I have the honor of presenting
an Academy Award to a national treasure,
- [Attendee] Yeah!
(audience cheering)
- The incomparable Angela Bassett,
in case you all didn't know.
I was blessed to work with
Angela in two beloved films,
"How Stella Got Her Groove Back"
and "Boyz n the Hood".
(audience clapping)
In "How Stella Got Her Groove Back"
Angela played the title role,
and I played her younger sister,
which was the easiest role I could imagine
because Angela really is a sister to me.
Truly.
My sister and I first crossed paths
on a little show called "227". (laughs)
(audience cheering)
You didn't know I was gonna bring
that one out on you, right? (laughs)
Only to later have our coming
out party in the same film,
John Singleton's "Boyz n the Hood".
(audience clapping)
Now, it's not often you
get to cut your teeth
in a history-making modern
classic, but we did.
And "Boyz n the Hood" is still studied
and celebrated today for many reasons.
But right at the top
is Angela's performance
as the unforgettable mother
fighting for her son,
the iconic Reva Styles.
(audience clapping)
Now, little did Angela know
that Reva Styles would send her on a path
to embody some of the
most significant women
of the civil right movement,
and become one of the
most in-demand actresses
of the next 30 years.
On screens big and small,
she has mesmerized us in over 100 roles.
(audience clapping)
But it's the quality, not the quantity
of her performances
that sets Angela apart.
I mean, let's talk about range, okay?
Who else could play Betty Shabazz twice?
(audience laughs)
Go on to playing a vampire,
then go from playing Rosa Parks
to a sports reporter,
and Coretta Scott King
to playing the Secret Service Director?
(laughs) I mean, not only did
she run the Secret Service,
she was a CIA director, a U.S. attorney,
a top official at 1600
Pennsylvania Avenue,
and an animated Michelle Obama.
(audience clapping)
(audience laughing)
Okay, that leads me to
ask you something, Angela.
With all that experience,
why aren't you running for president?
(audience laughing)
I'm down with it.
I mean, wait a minute.
Let's not forget her Tina Turner.
(audience cheering)
(audience clapping)
I revisit that film annually
and her performance still blows me away.
Okay, fun fact,
you remember this when
we were in Arrowhead
at our friend's house, you
pulled me up to sing back-up
for an impromptu karaoke session.
For a quick moment, I felt like an Ikette.
(audience laughing)
Man, bottom line, Angela has
lived a career for the ages,
and I swear she is ageless.
Truly beyond.
(audience clapping)
Angela's talent is something that everyone
who has worked with her
will share with you,
work with Angela on set and
you become her friend for life.
She has stitched a sisterhood that exists
simply because of who she is
as a woman and a human being.
And so many times I've heard people say
that Angela is the very
embodiment of Black excellence.
But let me correct that.
She has a perspective and a voice
and a beauty that is proudly Black.
But what she embodies at her core
is beyond anything that is skin-deep.
She is artistic excellence
embodied in human form.
(audience clapping)
(audience cheering)
(triumphant music)